generally speaking fascism comes from
the people who are wearing masks and
want to beat the [ __ ] out of people who
have a different opinion from them and
that is why this group needs to be
defined as a terrorist organization that
is not at all hyperbolic question of the
day do you think it's time to classify
an tyfa as a terrorist organization and
why do you support the president I'm
gonna say I do I absolutely do this is
one thing I'm 100% behind the President
on let me explain to you why I think
they fit the definition of a terrorist
organization so over the weekend and
this is something that it was really
hard to sort of we had to aggregate
these clips so thank you to everyone
who's who's taken some of these videos
and if we don't give you credit please
let us know um over the weekend Portland
they staged a counter protest or
demonstration against the proud boys
antiphon
and according to the media in at the
Portland Mayor Ted wheeler it was quite
peaceful on the other side was an Tifa
now as far as I've seen so far no
reports of significant violence thank
god from either scientific okay given
the continuing no number of people
involved I'm grateful that this was
largely a peaceful event really the
Portland Police had committed beforehand
to not send officers and any crowds
before the event they admitted there was
a possible that crimes occurred outside
the view of the officers oh my gosh and
when we say there are no reports will it
make me because you don't report it
there is footage from the event like
like lots
[Applause]
no hammer so heavy that look at this
they're just this is the guy they're
going after he throws one guy down
completely unconscious right and then
they're going back up the hammers and
then this guy I need you I need you to
calm down sir
and we'll have some more context in
those clips later which are important
but by the way that's one thing whatever
the left they say no one has ever been
killed by antiphon well it's that's not
true but they haven't killed as many
people because they just suck at it
a hammer and a window couldn't do it
yeah I think one of them hit themselves
yes well it's not for lack of trying
either alright but he hit himself with a
hammer that's tear cuts the sharp blade
of a pool toy hammers weeded out that
major consideration being given to
naming a terrace organization that you
would be watching closely and of course
the left was upset about this saying
that well how could you declare an TIFF
a terrorist organization when down there
there are white supremacist groups and
they're the ones who commit actual
violence and we'll get into why that is
entirely inaccurate as it relates to
Portland and an two foot large but
president I think you got a lot of
people who sign a petition here for
point one this is what the Left uses and
I think this is why when you designate
them a terrorist organization they say
that an Tifa they aren't terrorists
because they really aren't that violent
they're known as anti fun they're also
known for being violent but for a group
that's getting so much air time for
being violent and dangerous they're not
causing that much havoc I forgot he was
still in that clip beautiful and brave
not a word beautiful under here
something before we get into the
metadata I guess I don't know if that
really applies in this context but maybe
we personally infiltrated antiphon they
were handing out knives brought
sawed-off shotguns we're talking about
shooting people to ben shapiro protest
and by the way our footage led to some
arrests
I have like on the border between just
regular right what does that mean that's
a guy by the way coulda fooled me well
that's what he's trying to do is fool
you and then sue you for not using the
right pronoun fooling yourself don't
forget antfee member tried to bomb a
nice facility and even shot when his
rifle Jim so yet again again antiphon
not so adept at using hammers or
cleaning their rifle thank God just get
some ballast doll or hops number nine
you ask that's what your madam then
there's the Dayton shooter by the way an
aunt if a member or supporter likely
both who praise the ice fire bomber as a
martyr right this is important to note
that the left tries to throw everything
under the umbrella right now they said
well white supremacist right white
supremacy this isn't a response to white
supremacy and they well horn what's
white supremacy if you look at aunt or
the signs the shirts it says if you vote
for Trump you're racist yeah so they're
throwing everybody including anyone who
has a Mogga hat at their local church
has white supremacist and that's what
they're fighting when they see that they
are anti-fascist I want to make this
really clear right now that's not what
I'm doing I'm not saying all liberals
just like they say all white supremists
alternate voters or white supremacists I
am talking about an tyfa you anti-fur
specifically your violent crimes by the
way any mass murders occurred from
people who are actively members of the
proud boys how about Patriot prep cups
we were talking about here in Portland
I'm not in any gang I guess yeah that's
identified as a gang some people call it
a gang prep boys I just think you end up
with some people who are looking for a
bar fight and they won't leave until
they have a fight
that being said any mass murderers who
declared themselves to be proud boys or
in the name of proud boys or Patriot I
want to know because we just named some
from antiphon not white supremacists not
Trump voters not people who might have
had racist views now proud boys that's
what happened in Portland any go ahead
please send them we're talking identify
we're not even talking about the
Socialists liberals who shot up
Republicans because of a Bernie Sanders
supporters just addressing an tyfa hit
the notification bell by the way if
you're subscribed or just bookmark this
page check back every day we upload a
new video every single day that's the
way to beat the algorithms of course you
get a full daily show like seventy five
percent more content if you join one
club atlético club another argument the
left makes they shouldn't be a terrorist
organization they say well there's a
lack of organization
right they say they can't be a terrorist
organization because they don't have a
leader they don't have a clearly defined
charter or roster that's that's
literally their strategy that's to try
and remain anonymous yeah and keep in
mind they're still organized enough for
us to infiltrate that's important than
not we got on there encrypted messaging
apps and they meet up and they try to I
guess create this illusion that there is
no central organization yeah that's not
the case we've seen it firsthand when
you're talking about a terrorist
organization you don't just need to say
do they have a Ross do they have a
roster of leaders do they have some kind
of a manifesto it's very clear wherever
they go there's they're congruent sort
of acts of violence one of which is a
very clear anti police officer ideology
all cops are bastards will not even
throw bastards because they all
generalize wait a minute they all
profile blacks so you have a problem
generalization all cops are bastards
also race traitor yeah exactly right
they were saying that that one black
officer I felt so bad for the guy he's
just sitting there trying to do his job
and you don't want anti-fur you're
turning people into conservatives by
doing this something else it's important
note their violence isn't directed by
the way just it you know they go this is
how it happens because they say well
homo second
all Trump supporters are white
supremacist they say yeah so that means
all proud boys that means people who are
basically men's Christian groups who
support Donald Trump and then what
happens is you go down go down the the
totem pole there and they're going after
the proud boys left and if I just
assaulted people who were passing by who
they thought might be conservative
I mean that that should seem like it is
like that those were not proud boys they
had long since left another point here
when we're talking about terrorist
organizations the US Federal Regulations
they they define domestic terrorism okay
as the unlawful use or threatened use of
force or violence by a group of
individual based and operating entirely
within the United States or Puerto Rico
without Florida so it does talk about or
any segment thereof in furtherance of
political or social objectives does an
tyfa fit this definition absolutely not
only do they fit the definition keep in
mind terrorism you don't necessarily
have to commit violence you have to
instill terror name Tiffa obviously does
that and then they go one step one step
further and actually commit acts of
violence they're a terrorist
organization plus plus these people are
enemies of the United States I think
that's important if they're enemies of
left right all American citizens who
want to have a conversation but I also
think would be important to classify
them as a terrorist organization because
then the mainstream media would have to
cover it more accurately hear that
because right now right without this
classification and they just as we
showed you earlier they said well it was
largely peaceful so that's talking about
an event inaccurately
but they speak about an tyfa at large in
accurately painting them as the good
guys it says it right in the name and
Tifa anti-fascism which is what they
were they're fighting listen there's
we're literal with the names not when it
comes to scary more living tradition i
think that a lot of people recognize
that when pushed self-defense is a
legitimate response to what supremacy
neo-nazi violence you wrote a him
problem is to equate the violence in
reaction against bigotry with the
bigotry itself is to misunderstand the
fact that when you go to cancer
treatment the radiation is tough
treatment but it is meant to remove the
cancer i don't think so he was part of
looking the show met before it's like
yeah this is good i'm gonna look really
smart so by his line yeah they're
beating the republican out of us
actually by that logic I agree
everything that they said that not all
punches are equal that you have to look
at a response to violence that violence
is not a completely inappropriate
response when it's conducted in
self-defense but keep in mind proud boys
again I'm not associated with them I'm
not I don't think I'm not a supporter of
joining groups because I think you get
this mass hypnosis and groupthink and
you get this amoeba that's the mob and
it's dangerous not a fan of it but proud
boys a lot of these groups were created
in response to antiphon Islands right
right they say and I love that too by
the way Canada my anti fascist National
Socialists stop at the word play well I
don't know gun control anti-free speech
higher taxes nationally whoa okay well
listen but they were racist what are you
yeah yes but here's what's important
these groups were created the reason the
proud boys were walking in Portland by
the way if anyone can send me any
footage here any footage from this
weekend to the proud boys assaulting
random people any footage of the
right-wing groups because they were
tarred and feathered as extreme
right-wing groups and maybe there were
some extremists any footage of them
berating cops and saying that all cops
are bastards bastards any of them
support the white supremacists right
I saw American History X they should be
worse than just walking through the
streets right and the leaving they were
created as a response to an tyfa
violence and if a claims of a response
to what fascism
what's fascism you see the t-shirts you
see the signs
anyone voting for Donald Trump the proud
boys had a clear reason defending Trump
supporters against violent leftists like
antiphon antitheses anyone who supports
Donald Trump as fascists therefore at by
their own logic as they've described
therefore they are warranting they are
deserving of violent action just for
having a Mogga think about that person
by the way what we're talking about
fascism fascism doesn't generally come
from a president who lowers taxes who
deregulation who supports free speech
and wants an armed populace yes
generally speaking fascism comes from
the people who are wearing masks and
want to beat the [ __ ] out of people who
have a different opinion from them and
that is why this group needs to be
defined as a terrorist organization that
is not at all hyperbolic I want to see
them behind bars or at least on
Southern Poverty Law Center's list come
on make them listen hey there YouTube
viewer if you like this video click one
of these other videos playing in a box
subscribe hit the notification bell you
may be wondering why after this
outlandish video this is such a straight
end card that's because we've recently
learned that end cards actually
determine the YouTube algorithm as it
relates to controversy on a sliding
scale so we have a yellow and it
escalates all the way to the word